hi I'm Sarah hey I'm Kyra we are going
to be drawing SpongeBob characters from
memory yeah did you grow up on SpongeBob
you did right one frog was like right at
the end of my kid cartoon watching
career like it was Ren and Stimpy
and then like I discovered girls so like
that should do it I feel about such a
man who is Andy yeah that's okay I
remember mr. Krabs patrick star Patrick
star star V is a starfish no he sure is
I wonder what gave it away
you know what his body shape is egg it's
like Oh or like a nice fall I feel like
sort of he's got a big old big ol body
little T limbs I've seen the spongebob
movie and I've never watched the show no
watch it every day as a kid I don't know
who's ND is okay so sandy is the
squirrel who lives in this big water she
is in the she's in a suit ya see then
this sort of it's got like a big glass
dome does he have a nose well you're
just gonna have to draw I didn't see if
he's not going to help me well not this
time
okay I don't think your heads like too
big she wears like mittens
she's got boots her body is pill-shaped
tails shapes kind of pill-shaped yeah
yeah I like also how his clothes if I
remember correctly just kind of they're
just like on his body like there's not
there's not much of volume I guess
they're just lines on an egg you know
what's weird is I can't remember her
tail now but like she's got to have a
tailor I eat like that saw that squirrel
is yeah I don't remember the tail being
like a prominent feature in her design
are you more of a spongebob or are you
more of a Patrick like my personality
I don't like it that's not a lot of
choices I feel like I'm hard-working
like spongebob but I do sometimes feel
like a Patrick like doesn't everyone
have a little Patrick inside of them
yeah a big cheeks she's got the buck
teeth I know that for sure
does she basically looked like like Bugs
Bunny with short ears yes actually
that's not totally inaccurate I think I
definitely made him way cuter than he
- I am so many really cute am I crazy or
does he have a big belt and does any
where it like all just got one look and
it's crab baby Patrick doesn't really
have a lot of clothes
yeah he's shirtless mm-hmm at least I'm
putting him shirtless and he's got pants
and I want to say that they're dark
purple you're not going to tell me if
I'm right are they you should try it out
yeah he's gonna give her a tail I don't
think she has I don't think she has no
she does have a tail she's gonna have a
tail yeah why can't I think of a tail
does he have anything else on his face
well yeah yes eyes obviously come on
something that makes mr. crabs like one
of the best crab designs in animation is
his eyes they're just like super
memorable and unique like if you saw
silhouette of him you would instantly
recognize it I can't remember if his
pants like actually go onto his legs I
I'm turning over that too I think like a
little bit yeah I just gave him like a
little shorts
so I'm her limbs being tubular and kind
of narrow she's not like a buff squirrel
she's got sort of a tiny head inside of
this big spacesuit tiny head it's crazy
how you can like watch a cartoon a
million times and like stare at these
cartoon characters forever but then the
moment someone's like draw it out you're
like I can't Wow okay oh god I'm almost
done oh my god you know why Jackie
because I kept it simple oh well I
should have done what you were doing I'm
even gonna shade him yeah no yeah no
yeah doesn't she I think she has a bow
like on the outside of her irrelevant of
her helmet I think she does or a flower
when I draw a flower is wrong what looks
like a bow to me alright you draw a bow
I'll draw a flower okay I think I'm done
I'm done - I know that there's gonna be
some details that I didn't get that I
didn't remember but I feel like overall
I feel like I got the construction right
I feel like the fact that I didn't give
him a nose was the right choice well you
know what now that we're not drawing any
more I I would like to confirm to you
that he does not he does not have a nose
good how do you think you did I think I
did really good I love this
drawing that I did he looks really cute
he's really happy it's making me happy
and I hope it makes you happy you sure
it will and I hope it makes the viewers
happy I think I got the bit that they
like of the general shape of him down
but I feel like I messed up on the
clothes for sure I'm not sure if I got
his clothes or if this is just like a
wishful thinking look it's just lingerie
for every that's just laundry and a babe
all right yeah I did god-awful I still
have no like image of who this person is
in my head other than an animal and
spacesuit yeah I didn't bail a button
for some reason I gave him the belly but
I forgot he's like ridges on his back oh
yeah I did not give him little ridges
mine does look like a really really like
cute version of Sam I also did not
remember he has weird little things on
his eyes I did remember those but I was
like trying my hardest to remember what
the eye-shine looks like she does of a
tail okay I am so funky I'm not I'm not
far up I'm on a different planet this is
pretty close that's not bad Oh yours is
so much more accurate it's so cute I
love his claws yours is gray this one
looks like one that did that Nickelodeon
sponsored oh thank you you gave him like
a like you gave him like gnome pants
yeah I love it and yours is perfect
you don't like dialed it wait well
I'm perfect you did do a full black eyes
as opposed to the white but like you got
the general shape of the face you got
the tin body the flower on the outside I
think you got a lot of it for someone
who's just seen like the movie and like
barely knows it's over ten years ago
really does anything about Spongebob
like this is pretty good we remembered
the same things we definitely did
we got the fact that he has a collar and
a pocket sorry guys gonna well he
doesn't have a pocket in this picture we
just have met old Mandela effect so we
just imagined that he had a box but he
doesn't yeah yours is so cute I would
like buy merch with this little crab on
it spongebob
its iconic and it's like definitely
permeated our culture and learning more
than most properties I'm gonna remember
it because you spend all your free time
as a child just watching television what
else am I gonna do pay my taxes I don't
have taxes yet I'm a I'm a kid I had
taxes when I was a kid no I didn't I was
gonna be like you are a really advanced
child prodigy
[Music]